[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello, my name is Roman
Nurik and welcome to This
Week in Android Development
on Monday, February 3, 2014.
Last week, Todd released
another iOS DevByte as well as
a PlayByte on Play
Games Best Practices.
Joe Fernandez taught us how to
record videos from our Android
devices using just
the USB cable and ADB.
And Paul Carff's
Super Secret DevByte
might actually be
unveiled this week.
To find out for sure, you
should subscribe to our channel.
Last but not least,
Android Design in Action
kicked off the first
episode of the year
with a review of the Beautiful
Design Winter 2013 collection.
This week be sure to look
out for a new episode of UXD
with Nazmul and Rich Fulcher
of Android Design Team, also
another Play Games
DevByte for iOS with Todd,
and another mystery
DevBytes with Fred.
We hope the suspense isn't
killing you yet because there's
much more to come in
the following week.
That's all for this week
in Android Development.
I'm Roman Nurik, and "we all
live in a yellow submarine,
a yellow submarine,
a yellow submarine."